jusqu'à bref la halle aux toiles dont
six habitées le mal que tu as en cours
pour de faire chier tu vas avoir du
fonds s'est ensuite des mathématiques
et puis tu auras bien la trique parce
que ça soit le matin et de maintenant
que le banc tu penses l'a fortement la
multi unique au heat avait prédit à
temps je pense qu'il ya un bal avec
confettis récup mettre le background
avec une couleur verte
attention il pourra rajouter des nuages
tu pourras rajouter plaindre vient donc
sa masse peau
ça nous fait vivre
mais c'est tout
[Musique]
ça va gueuler vous défoncer je les
prends de bar et je vais te la mettre
dans la peau de la vie c'est pas ça
[Musique]
ut jour en chantant
on fait
comme des petits ça nous fait
mais ce matin
[Musique]
[Rires]
on me dit
[Musique]
je l'apprends est tout à fait ok super
mal accordée
[Musique]
ah ouais
e
non
mais on peut estimer les
je
à
[Musique]
[Rires]
et